yeah
merci
you can
she means she needs another one
every four days welcome to imitate 1984
2009 take our usual emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate building would you please link
building our nearest available exit to
the chamber our assembly point will be
in the public car park at side Pacific
suite please don't delay your evacuation
by collecting any belongings please
don't return into the building of don't
give a permission to do so by council
staff please note that the meeting will
be audio recorded and if you have a
mobile phone with you please turn it off
water cycle thank you great item one is
apologies for absence they can receive
from councillor Merrick who isn't
substituted by councillor castilho
councillor mounteen who has been
substituted by counsel mr. Boies item to
non-members attending there are none at
the moment
right item four minutes of the meeting
how about the 22nd of March 2019 they
have people sign those as a correct and
accurate record of that meeting which
item five declarations of interest
I have found I have an akuna be
interested in item six as I'm a member
of the secretary committee because
committee act as a liaison between
residents and century and I'm not
involved in any strategic or player
decisions members we've had we have been
in advance of specific requests to swap
to bring item seven for to be the first
item notes any objection to that we've
got visitors are equally divided between
the two applications and we will
straight on to item seven and mr. Strang
is going to report on that one for his
first award okay
Thank You chairman this application is
to the site of one to six am revenue on
the eastern side of Humber and you'll
see their picture will show where they
used to be upon below and only Lucien
was granted acknowledge that bungalow is
subdivide the site in the front
so take me about 65 meters all the icons
there we could see two up three the
current application is a retrospective
application submitted under Section 7
create a companion app which allows the
developers between very the consent
rather than consider the whole
application will refresh to consider it
in terms of the changes and that's done
by substituting plans we required on the
government and the changes you'll see
here are all three under the language on
this you can see them below to the front
of one of two behind the side a you'll
see that the sighted l-shaped up three
there we're looking at the detailed
design for block one doubly design
changes that consistent amongst all
three twenty times the overall height is
reduced by half a meter and what's
happened the roof design details have
ended up in sort of like a lowering of
the walls so the proof elements was
dropped and the applicant has also
increased the recourse in if you could
see on those borders he's raised it by
about three courses because there was an
issue where the windows making the
render before it could be unable to fry
etc so it was a good idea to reduce the
proportion about and raise the height of
the bridge plane there is a change
internally to provide a ensuite bathroom
to one of the
what that's necessitated is a small
window in the existing pattern on the
real renovations that has been cutting
in obscure biting and the narrow opening
vents to allow ventilation is in excess
at the 1.7 meters that the conditions
require the drawing to the bottom
there's one other change there Jeff
chairman the window details a bit finer
that was previously approached when the
Planning Commission was considered
rigidly they had a Georgian society
isn't conservation area so the change in
design to the windows office is fear
let's just imagine type material changes
much easily noticeable now
the will see from the report that the
windows where they only look as I said
with the high level of the base they're
close to Windows at the back 1.65 links
a high window here but you know the
looks as you'll see on this plan the
bottom of the garden of this property
there's windows in this woman already on
the back of the extra we know is
provided they go across the garden and
then across the rear gardens here you
can see from those the upstairs doors to
these properties and then the window in
the back board here we'll notice
architectural sideways onto the back
that looks at a great pool and a high
level Reno in this property which is
nice out to do those so officers
consider them the overlooking issue by
the extra window isn't really material
after course objection the the height
issue lowers the height of the buildings
compared to what was previously found
acceptable and all the other issues of
garden areas and things they don't
really form part of the assessment at
this stage is just the changes to the
bill really subjective revised plans
there is a storage issue that members
can see in the officer report is that
one issues the floor space you'll see
has been modified because of the
provision of the ensuite and what that's
done because previously the original
approval and a wider wall area here with
some cupboard space that's lock that
down this building requires two square
meters of darkness cupboard space
storage drops it so that's one way just
under 1 meter so there is an issue that
the storage space in the top one in
particular is undersized now the
applicant could improve that by rotating
that cupboard
national standards that apply on that
point the national standards were
brought in for a consistency amongst
those authorities like much that they
had obviously been variously defined
through sizes for spices etc but the
government felt there was a need for the
anything warm developers to have a
consistent approach where capsules like
ourselves have a standard haven't had
their different variations
whew I take isn't that mr. the industry
to be able to do economies of scale I
don't think the government having mine
it was to ensure a certain amount of
lenity members Motoko a view on that
no doubt but we'll see from the report
Jim that recommendation is approved just
before I get to that series next on the
end that you can see the members
the recommendation is going to subject
this chapter here and move on everyone
did have a copy of agenda we want to
speak to on this one I missed before
up to five minutes I'm looking now in
the government need to go okay thank you
very much mr. chairman
quite soon I haven't come up here to
criticize the planes I have what we will
focus by seven individual didn't
materialize and lots of issues did
promise to us at a public meeting about
what am I about here today is that we
have major water issues a sensitive that
development started including the
Builder is also faces more to issues we
might talk to you particularly like but
extreme the other ones from my garden
that was Christmas when the development
started and it was down right before my
garden down my driveway constrained to a
public highway and also I've got water
sitting on the top of my car that was
not ever had before
I believe it's paused and that's our
political you have to have a safe and
expert advice that's given to me is that
we pointed out the very beginning when
this planning effort was put forward in
writing telephone calls the public
meters are so on that there was a stream
that was along the perimeters of these
guards and it was filled in and the
stream has gone underground when the
films that put the sunset for the
subways is disturbed that stream and
that probably why he's got the water
problems in as far as on the side that
it's now had to abandon the drainage and
department their water from the tank
into the road rains to off aside from
the
from the building clock but that doesn't
stop the problem that we've got
there's West us we've got surface water
to sit in their gardens this is
throughout the winter and we've got this
stream that's coming through now I
really shouldn't be here tonight because
I've found the Planning Department
numerous occasions and work letters I
even wrote a letter to suss in Essex
County Council pointing out the issues
of them we've got water by the strength
of their cars it's a highway they turn
returning back to watch the castle isn't
impressive it's a building area and
today we deal with and they've done
nothing I've not even return my calls
not in we have despite when I spoke sort
of plan the last week he said I'll get
the gentleman concerns of foam unit and
he's not done so purpose I want we're
here tonight is because this map nine of
us who have got major water problems
from this side now we're just dry that
obviously with the warm weather that
we're now getting and so that probably
won't appear copy 2x winter but we can
need some advice
we need some expert advice on how we're
going to deal with the drainage that
damaging that gardens and damaging air
closes but Watford Council has failed in
its duty of care survey students made in
device in us they've probably advised to
build up but they're not advice and the
residents and when we want suffer the
largest building project this country
has ever seen since the Second World War
what faith does that give us as
residents mr. chairman we would like
some help on the water
we've got I think the build has resolved
it
spoke to him just now in big-ass days
he's now taking the water from his area
and it's got permission to put it into
the road rains and away we haven't got
that luxury thank you thank you my
members - you're aware
despite the buttons made by our speaker
today we've got a clear focus for what
we need to look at and we we are looking
at three particular items one is the
reduction in height of the roof two is
the addition of an additional window
obscure three is the relative
proportions of render and brickwork and
then whether we find the slight issue
with internal storage of sufficient
merit the planning point there the
particular points that we need to
consider so I'll put it to you that I'd
be happy to move for the approval on
this one because those three items do
not seem to me to be material to
Planning Commission that's there anyone
else not contribute
Thank You Jimmy
I'm just going to answer the gentleman's
question that that's not a plantation
area so I've got to focus you or -
what's it you know well I'll come to
that later we must focus on the planning
issues specifically here what's the
original claim of the height of the
windows that's been passed as we as we
know it and yet now moved to higher the
windows because they put three courses
of brickwork is that correct that's good
so yeah this the roof line has come down
so the proportions of the window in the
wall proportions I'm just asking is the
high the windows higher than what they
was original what's that indeed the
detail of that room coming out the my
office Jim what's happening to detail on
the broker fees the actual roof elements
you can see it's the same fight it's
lower overall the window is being
compressed what happened with the
brickwork the rendered detail and the
previous went down a lot lower because
of technical issues been going around
that we know surrounding the damage of
our ability to render is thinner at that
strip the owner chose to basically build
more brickwork in the water rather than
the amount of rent so the wall elements
on the plant we
between the tip that's enough about half
for me to the roof elements is the sum
over all particles is half a meter up
that's also pretty answer mr. Griffin
both chairman but I haven't visited plum
row Avenue for some time how far as the
construction proceeded are we just
talking about foundations at the moment
well can i again I'm going to be a
little bit here whether the item has
been built not been built his heartfelt
isn't relevant to us determining the
Planning Commission we are looking at
whether planning permission is propria
for what is presented to us
right sorry to stare you but better that
that question wouldn't be relevant to us
making the decision but never that thank
you for information
Kevin enters the the roof is on the
internal waterline they just require
internal decoration the roof is on
weather type windows award in windows
talk about being on supplies etc stage
thank you mrs. Draper's thank you
Thank You Jenny can you just tell me
that there's only one additional window
from the original development the effect
is that gem is my locker it's my
understanding the additional window is
that it serves the ensuite in each each
people
okay members you have a recommendation
for approval with the condition system
so rather than favor of the approval
these indicators
I was going
but I to mr. Herod mr. Hall mr. Matthew
Thomas here who's a head of development
was undertaken to speak to you
personally tomorrow at our time of your
choosing to discuss the specific issues
that you've got an Town Council and
various systems well we've got the top
man they know about to see okay thank
you very much
I'm anyone who stopped for that items I
can stop for the rest but we we now move
on to item 6 which is the redevelopment
former prison complex provide various
housing for work for horrible Lane pop
wind strength assert a state this way
nope I should quit 1/7
part 7 looks like a link to an assistant
director the recent of tomatoes I've
been instructed to support exactly make
sure symmetric usually of English point
five seven seven right so so that's from
the assistant director community and
housing who fully supports is not
instructing us [ __ ] but he doesn't
say that sobbing this planet that boy
this application is the cycle former
prison most reputable it's very useful
to the amount extant
within the prison and out of prison
wardens but if we zoom out a bit
hopefully like members to also know to
extend the various art standing areas
that are outside the prison compound
they're relevant because although this
site is in the Greenbelt members will be
aware that you can redevelop the
previously developed land that's been
used like this you can also actually
develop the hard surface seriously and
that's what it was
to seek those areas the members will see
from the report that this site really
has outlined Planning Commission before
the sixties weapons to the site plan the
current application is not parked at
that outlet that's perhaps unusual why
often we grant that my permission of the
receding course reserve matters come
through the second part this is spend
alone application independent of the
outline this is a full in its own right
so we're showing detailed designs
environment but the receiver Alliance
part of the development is where the
prison buildings stand the architectures
try to use these surface areas that I
was alluding to earlier on but a lot of
interest in is brought the openness I
think this is currently compound crime
you believe the open spaces that we take
into the development we've accepted that
the necessarily fudgy innovation event
to achieve that setting is acceptable
you will also see that the parking areas
to the west of the existing block
courthouses the areas in blue on a part
of an application is something car
parking area up there's got a terrace of
three lanes and there is two terraces
and a pair on the area to the south in
the previous outline the development
when nervously brightness is turned
through 90
Tereza game that you were trying to get
a better setting for these buildings
this scheme here that you see before is
4:14 five-bedroom attached houses 13 4
bedrooms detached houses the poor been
taken to different designs in five
minutes with reading Amazon's is 18 3
bedrooms semi houses in layering
taraskin senators hatch formed and there
is also two buildings at the top here we
nine one bedroom and nine two bedroom
facts members will see from the layout
that it's in small pockets served by
road the road that you see make surprise
move your highway standards it's got the
required visitor spaces that you can see
located parallel to the right of ways
the open design a rather like that
rather than the herring bug enroll or
driving in half side supermarkets this
has more of a residential taste and
flavor to it that's supported by the
designer and if you've got very keen eye
you'll see that some of these areas of
God they were referring to as refuge
layups I think for our purposes tonight
assume their preference of people
collection areas because everybody's got
gardens and access
the reference bins will be stored on
their property most of the time the
layouts were they up so it would allow
an area for collection day just just a
flat surface distinguish
cetera accommodated that part of the
open road the time for talking so we
feature the development is also pliable
with your parking standards all these
spaces and gary spaces that you
preferred a higher standard the road
widths etcetera were capable of taking
emergency vehicles or service vehicles
if we could jump to to plan 150 please
this is the revised design and that came
through going on the advice of the urban
designer to make this is the solar after
two apartment locks make it look more
farm like to be you see from the report
that there are balconies recessed to
each flag that composes your vital areas
we require for edited space that the
ambition from the urban designer he felt
in you get a proper setting we try and
take some references in the it's not
about that he felt that there was a need
to include detailing two respective bars
as you follow
we can jump to the other apartment block
this is the larger block that members
will say there's actually an l-shaped
format it just returns a common area
called on the diameter and if we can
jump to the street things they throw
members will see the pier of the
apartment blocks that we were just
looking at hopefully members can
appreciate palette of materials that are
proposed in the various design forms
through a blend of the overall
composition the development proposed if
we could just hover on the 10-year plan
the affordable housing is essentially
grouped in this part with another
Terrace of three over here obviously the
waving affordable housing works from the
council's list
most of the people on mr. small
households think of one or two bedrooms
so the apartments satisfy that need and
they have their own setting within close
car park that we enjoy
the cities that are then proposed live
nine two bedroom houses this this six
there the dark the lighter blue is for
social rent and the darker color is with
a burgundy color and Weston see they are
the ones that are parking part shared
path so travel could take the where
though I am going over it couldn't that
be willing to hello chairman the lighter
blue social venting ones that these the
apartments and what we want and then the
first two pays here then those four part
equity are that one day ever and the
terrace of stirring they're all the
houses are move two bedroom two houses
again it reflects the point I made need
for smaller households from this members
may also see before we leave it to that
there's a cycle shed here and a pumpkin
station they are sort of substation
election substation the architects have
make them garage like in appearance
rather than some other block tonight
area
appearance if we can jump back to the
cyclone preflop members will see from
the report that the bullet is acceptable
highway modeling was undertaken for the
outlines placement 75 units now with the
outline approved of 60 and well inside
the model but this is uplifted into 72
remembers may recall from the other
application although I would suggest
that the applicant is now thinking of
restoring all recorded 112 the planning
approval was granted about line D degree
into the subdivision of this with three
women so you can take three from this
and essenti to overall in the statement
takes it up to the 75 we don't know what
the future will be football definitely
the time that the applicant is
considering whether to run during the
design it equates to a density of twenty
five twenty haight air over the thirteen
twenty we have normally seen just as a
standard
we've got constraints by way of not only
the highway access but also the pattern
of development in relation to the extent
of developed language so officers take a
view that the amount of consummate
development here is about right in terms
of your density policies and also
there's a healthier 20 makes the
previous outline Commission without
going on about seeing that was only an
indicative members what we call back
into the predominance of four and five
bedroom houses based on the vacant
building credit
at that time the developers for this
come along with a lot helps again let me
switch when you look at the appendix one
that's more significant one though
you'll see this is a variable - it is
the five bedroom on that clock there now
that's got nine of eight screaming -
shortfall so it's 90 something square
hundred but yours end of the site where
two joins an area open space attempting
to take away this is a new wedding it's
not squeezed into a street scene
somewhere where there's a risk in a
character or density this is a
development in its own setting and
unusually this doctor benefit all this
openness on this side now as your policy
says that sort of your guidance says
that you can take account
if you the relative spectate Thank You
members
after the addendum was published we
received these comments from a resident
in the vicinity of our email so if you
have an address for but I'm required to
read these further comments before you
proceed and I say I agree with some of
my neighbors that it is potentially
overdevelopment the site of anything
welcome I propose pre-orientation some
of the homes I think too many homes of
the century planning facing the wrong
direction I'm supposing a different
layout attacks into performance which
makes more of the best features of this
site if all Gardens amuse myself then
give the greater opportunity the solar
panels to be installed an important
environmental consideration more
productive gardens and more some
tourists visitors away that's benefiting
their health my sketch shows that the
road will be shorter and have less
impact on pedestrians making it safer
also there are also other benefits to
this scheme with the main line share of
the site with the prison port very my
members that in addition to this there
is the officer officer of this area so
I'd near the existing dwellings this a
total of 64 words weddings when you
it's more than the outline less than
their engine placement this is an idea
that's been put forward by a resident
University just heard
to summarize acceptable the buildings
have you seen would be a good design
there's good off street parking and
layout recommendations therefore
approval is set out in the report
subject we a contingent of agreement
under section 106 of the terms okay
speaker on this one is mr. Todd none
five minutes I'll let you know when you
got a minute together very much good
evening gentlemen
I'm Robert Todd man solicitor neighbors
next door
my head got I would love to tell you
I'm told that for 25 minutes and
therefore I had to say
is it working that creatively sorry
thesaurus new yeah
the list of objections exhibited in the
development communities agenda and 1-3-1
own and not have a single track road
with a public footpath which is
designated to be down the middle of the
road to service 72 houses 200 people
without passing days and papers the
footpath is used frequently by local
uses runners focus walking groups
organized by Authority riders and
cyclists and also children walking to
bus stops all of which will be made to
mingle in the road together with what
will be about 250 cars of death why are
we in this predicament because some
years ago the prison lost all their
deeds they hadn't a clue what they owned
and they assume that they owned all of
all would warm lane that an actual fact
sounds of it
celebrations it was found out that they
are totally wrong and they've lost all
their deeds and when they came to
registration they hadn't gotten anything
they could register and therefore the
owners at the time which was Harrow
housing perpetuated and they accepted
position and accepted that they own none
of the road to only building actually
having rights but is the Talmud headin
in now
it's a time that
yeah
it's interesting to note from the
documents of Land Registry the fair
housing purchase from the Minister of
Justice
wool would fall four million eight
hundred thousand and entered into an
oath rate agreement which is simply
terms provided for the home office to
contribute funds for improving access to
sight amongst other things
Harrow through its holding company bread
road so onto the charitable company
Saints rehousing for 11 million pounds
making a profit of six million two
hundred thousand this is obviously going
to have to be recruiting so the single
track road is storing that trouble for
everyone in the state in 50 years the
way our population is increasing and the
need for more housing to Nathan further
development demands a proper access road
notice the access road wasn't the thirds
of in the report a few minutes ago that
comprises roads should be financed
by taking advantage body over agreement
under that home office agreement if this
is done by foot him it separately
overage from the home office would
supply much of finance to the charity
involved the real value to sanctuary in
Buller fall is to come in future years
the development they get on the other
I think it's 35 acres which they have on
the site it is wrong to expect people to
come onto this estate
unless they have a two way road onto
that estate he can open an existing Road
because you've got the yet preserved
building as we're talking this way but
it could come from one of the four sites
which are available to bring in a road
in another base we have no objection
whatsoever to
development it is the access which is
going to cause for some happiness [ __ ]
you there
would you like to know what we'd like to
do oh I'm sorry we have to be absolutely
regress with our our protocols was we
become subject to challenge for the five
minutes of the five minutes and I didn't
use
if it aint magenta my goddess 22-point
do not be thank you right members can
open this to discussion now
it's yet another super cool but they're
about 3/4 ladies previous applications
chairman up I think when I product at
that first we didn't involve the
previous about bankers but also here you
might sorry sorry chairman firstly the
policy background back then was slightly
different in as much previously
developed land didn't have the status at
his head since the NPP everything in
2012 but I think to be fair where I saw
the plan was it wasn't previously to go
and anyway that's why I made the point
when we started the presentation to it
pretty members mine the cement of the
hard standing areas and the prison wall
was that significant in the decision
authority as opposed to the remainder of
the sites under 35 acres I think
the development preparedness has to be
largely concentrated mr. clarify
honoring the build existing lives on the
site listed that although this is
sanctuary I'm a little unclear on
exactly what have we here
social housing estimate that's going to
work on this does it meet requirements
of 35 percent on deploring there there's
a section there to the west of the area
which is auditing Broome just clarify
what that is please and just to clarify
with the glass the excess growth is that
part of this application
they switch get questions on line up
when we first catch mr. Hyde
thank you I won't just want to start by
sound I think yes I understand the
offices of which that the failures makes
out what extenders they are small but
they are local gong sites and on
internal spaces I think that's tends to
be indicative of development whereas in
the past but I understand there is the
advice we are given by them as well go
to the it doesn't got hurt development
pretty too many on one spot and it does
you know just like to know is it for
additional knowledge for me to take
forward what is so hard about moving a
few fixed panels which would be the case
of a particular goal does it encroach on
language cannot be developed there to
the signal track road which cancer
centers refer to as well but just basics
my waist don't seem to look to that in
relation to the application itself they
seem to value the relational comics
building relations to destruction
traffic with 200 knots on a proposal to
the point when it was it
297 server makes them thick and weakness
today that's it
can't find it once yeah that's exactly
yeah I thought that would be folly
excessive instruction
we're just just so get going this XY
waves
I'm not even dictating they've actually
built up issues that I think are
important I think other pastors think
they've gotten the single trap rob has
been raised in construction traffic it's
been raised by residents it's been
raised again mister totten enticing
Silas it just totally failed sir let's
make it so the final point penalty on
seven pages I know actually the report
and occasionally there is the report
says in paragraph 537 on page six point
three six
as a result massive the appointment for
reading the difference would be provide
surprises lots the northeast corner of
the site in the mix of vaccinators north
week dot please dr. pepper party music
you slice their positive expectancy
these sitting room Y can be described as
top seed just races there what pepper
continue to sound food it's a block only
one isn't a lot or not Northwest or it's
where I sure it's northeast corner he's
aligned north-south northeast corner and
aside the very top corner is the
affordable
Cousy that really to me doesn't wait why
us analyse a difficulty when I read I
agree that of the sanctuary art on
nominally major social how do you
provide bellowing the space they're
actually a construction company they
should really rethink this thing it's
the same way chairman is required that
property is a 5-bit not we have to
understand that yeah so obviously we
take 3-4 months maybe five children in
there it's not much room for everybody
can that be can that be altered in any
way God made two defensive elements or I
mean the saturation point
Azzam
as previously on the access road because
I think I read somewhere in the report
there was certain places
those are unofficial how you get them
official from like some clarification on
what an unofficial personal basis
because the way I see it that will turn
out to be residents driveways
we have anymore Okwe Thank You chairman
yes what we've burnt number of the other
councillors the issue of the access road
great sir I would also like to know as
to whether if they an access road
between built to us on the site like
this as the weather you know what is
existing being a standard that we would
be required
if a new road was built insuring would
have to be a much higher standard what
is there the I would also like to know
mrs. Frank's you mentioned about the
total number of dwellings and does that
include the existing ones that are in
the blue art areas not just the book
itself does that include the
okay the question to mr. chairman
backwards first the area's edge below is
this all word problem which is on your
local base there are no distant
buildings down this but there are misty
buildings at the top right that these
orbital receptors of local interest is
not statute clearly protecting excessive
building policies would like to retain
buildings to this side they think that
former prison officers caught it was
also like the hospital building
single senior staff I think this may be
corrected by the locals with this I
think that's the married quarters were
now the modeling that was done my
understanding is they were looking at
the prison use I think transport
assessment looked at comparisons
explaining the traffic that would go to
the prison to degree of inmates that all
three the changing rotors of staff and
not a highways engineer but there is a
database called treaty Ric yes the
highway engineers rely upon for their
faces for comparisons and the modeling
that was done to my understanding was
that they were swapping or trying to
compare the activity of the prison with
the activity of the development before
them and that commodity chains were
capacity with the improvements that have
been done to seventy-five households so
it didn't include these because these
were part of the equation they need the
part of the prison activity in the for
the news and they're not part of the
planning application now so you
nice the passing places that the term
unofficial is what the applicants have
used in their transport state there are
it's not related to the drive things
which are up here means familiar with
excitement know that this is the speaker
same but the houses are quite coast
including some of their starting points
but when you leave this place and go out
to this ministry concrete road as you
drive down through the tree-lined area
there are five lay buyers they're quite
large into public are saying thank you
no reason things like this the applicant
themselves is called one official or
unofficial but they have been there and
operated for a great number of years
what the term efficient is I'm afraid I
can't help those parking spaces are down
there why we're on that the previous
outline application obviously broke the
ice because the number of issues and one
of the concerns that came on the outline
it's not a concern on this application
but the county's specialist advisor on
district buildings was concerned in the
relatively narrow part up here when we
first leave the highway the listed
buildings are quite close and what his
concern was was that you can get to
safety to deliveries of cement perhaps
coming out and coming in those vehicle
to meet each other they're likely to
bump up the Verge's etc they're likely
to you know the trees and the wires and
things as they try and pass and there
was a need to manage that
the transport statement that accompanies
the planning application talks about the
provision of traffic lights or a batsman
guys like I've stopped going or whatever
so that they would manage the
construction traffic year and they would
hold the extra traffic in the babe eyes
that we've just referred to so the
management at this point too is not so
much for the residential development
itself some members have picked up its
to do with the construction vehicles
risk of damaging their heritage assets
that are top of the of the site the
reduced garden area that has been
suggested it might be possible in the
layout to move the fences on time what
you have to look at is that most of the
architecture and setting of the stand is
your guidance does society you can relax
that sure where our property enjoys an
open space now if the developers would
mind if for whatever reason plan to do
that probably fairly easy fixed if they
were minded not to do that and when to
challenge it we could go into an appeal
situation attention if we're trying to
convince an inspector that on the one
hand we say guidance well we can reduce
that garden area
open space we'd have to have a special
reason why in this case we wouldn't be
willing to follow that so I think it is
possible to move the fence out and try
to do it it's a funny condition the only
thing I'm slightly concerned about this
is a number of trees in this like part
of the second period and I don't know if
the architect has deliberately brought
the fences in so that they wouldn't
encroach towards those the singletrack
round as I said earlier has been
assessed in life in the county highways
and they've done a comparison on the
traffic inside I think members are right
that this was cleaning field with no
previous use you'd be look tyria
adoptable roads where vehicles can pass
etc but they have to balance event the
almond use and the impact on the highway
network that's why miss Lisa don't model
275 dwellings on on this area being a
city that he plays with performing if
that's why they find this acceptable and
if the developers wanted to have more
housing if they were to come back and
suggest with a new application with
greater densities then I think the idea
of existing access being unworkable
horse of rethink on the answers but
what's before members tonight is an
escape that the Highway Authority hadn't
looked at the information provided
looked at the modeling of grief its
assumptions and assessments they find
that this equates with highway toes to
what's acceptable very in mind that the
previous application and other
modifications of the affordable housing
is 37% I think that that equation in the
number of units you normally around you
round out now I believe this applicant
is a usual affordable housing provider
it's my understanding that the housing
associations because of the hadn't
they've been dealt with nationally and
they're financing they are now acting
like commercial developers and perhaps
that the profit they would get from the
private Castile's that would feed into
the short from their giving at the
national level to provide affordable
housing so because of the name of the
applicant
it is not 72 affordable houses out there
but you might be seen as a couple of
years ago this is a schedule for 72
dwellings of which 37% of them are a
father
with your policy they blue areas I think
I pointed out forward to here
staff quarters there who hasn't us
pretty much members have expressed
concern I think members are keen that
affordable housing should be Pepperpot
it about that's definitely an aspiration
but the realities are when you have
houses scattered individually throughout
that the management of those no share
roofs the facilities etc you eventually
end up needing customers maintenance the
garden is mates it's the drains etc they
need pockets and clusters now the idea
behind an epic optimism in old days
affordable housing used to be generally
built with a different bridge a
different brief time you go around the
state and immediately see where the
affordable housing was by design the
design process improved on these
buildings will be finished in materials
to form the character that they had by
virtue of the shape and design of the
buildings and by the materials that you
see did not know where the affordable
housing
like get over them by design but by
virtue of organization for those public
that's right the apartments are in their
own setting and by organization as well
the other group of affordable housing
here at least six houses there are a
long side of I was call me in a cluster
of 18 plus 6 and then you've got another
group over here as 3 and normally a
cluster of twenty-something is probably
about right in terms of management
problem notes are 50 60 21 items might
be overwhelmed so I think with this
there is an acceptable cluster which is
what I think you can expect I think you
hold out to get pepper potting of a
scattering of these notwithstanding
through the activities that they have
tenure over the whole block to start
with at least I don't think you'll
achieve pepper party management point
that just doesn't work they have to have
groups and clusters of dwellings now
that's the way they they operate
okay
to come back after - yes name just what
question just confirm that the access
road is not the block petite place as
well by morally that is more in
Stanley's Essex County Council
what is the answer next week don't have
block not adopt the roads on that site
unless the access road to exert some
property was just an issue of ethics and
consideration by organizing the road the
access road is adopted as well and also
just come back on the epic modular
clustering I'm looking to reads a
cluster of housing
just thought the future could we this is
again where Essex highways don't wear
their side of this place we accept that
they have to look to this adult and
they're applying to thee this is not
really another application which comes
in and they're silent on it and we don't
know the answer I really wish sometimes
we go back back to them
just asking for clarification about each
other so under this I've created an
event from night it's a dog from an
excellent always appointment presuming
that the road network on the science
doesn't meet your standards
if the link road is question
questionable west of weathering which is
a private robot how does that fit in
with the overall scheme and does
would be gallery if it is a private
product what what management setup is is
there is there is there any information
about the management setup theories or
the site common areas roads stuff like
that makes that big detailed chairman I
can tell members that the another player
from see before you is always the doctor
from standards adopted one thing I did
neglect this area to avoid to provide it
sure I don't know what I would do
because the land no no what you now st.
remember I was the whole 35 acres they
would obviously for the private sales in
particular they would convey a right to
access maps you think the mountain
climber ownership enter this area
in such a sweat pathway etc
the usual things that the applicants
would have to invite right of access to
those people and presumably they a
maintenance obligation which is easily
done no charge to the future members we
just have to be careful about the
direction of status at the road it's
planning that were specifically looking
at their final point just about family
but I have noticed in these previous
applications the road has to be closed
for one day so to continue to be a
private road is that the case that's I
think this is stretching from work they
answered that one later but not direct
and planning related so members you've
got a recommendation for our fruit will
starting gather page three six point
three eight moving through 26.4 to those
members is taper off the approval please
indicators
kick those guys
that item is passed thank you very much
for your attendance now